the united nations posted a real
a a real magnificent tweet the other day
this was a work of art in the ridiculous
leftist twitter game
un women which is a separate account
tweets out how to not be a man splainer
you know a mansplainer they say you can
avoid being a mansplainer by asking
yourself
these questions did she indicate any
desire to hear this information
is it possible that she knows more about
this topic than i do
did i read the room before starting to
speak
did i and then it gives the definition
of mansplaining
i cannot wait to mansplain to these
people
how we defunded this stupid organization
i am going to be so excited
if i ever have any uh degree of uh
political influence in this area where i
can deal with the un
i am going to build the most beautiful
waterfront condominiums there i mean
maybe we'll we'll we'll lease out
the trump name it'll be nice big trump
luxury condominiums
because surely that would do more good
for the world than this stupid
organization the united nations which
accomplishes
nothing good lots of bad things wastes a
lot of time
and grievance mongers and the united
nations itself
is part of this problem we've been
talking about all day this problem of
the perfect utopian theory coming up
against the reality because the u.n in
theory what you get all the nations of
the world to come together
and we deliberate and we all figure out
how to live together in kumbaya
we all live in peace in reality what the
u.n does is empowers
the worst people in the world it puts
the worst regimes on earth
that slaughter their own people puts
them on the human rights council
it gets all of these awful it invites
the worst tin pot dictators in the world
to come to the united states we pay for
most of the thing
and or at least the lion's share of the
thing and they criticize america
why do we do that because the people who
establish the united nations
are the same people who think we can
overcome human nature
we can i mean this is the progressive
project right the
kind of more conservative and
traditional idea is that human nature is
fixed it's not changing there are
certain laws of the universe and we need
to
govern ourselves in accordance with that
that's what the entire federalist papers
is about
then progressivism comes in and says oh
forget all that that was all written in
the age of newton where we thought there
were eternal truths and fixed
laws but we're in the age of darwin
where we know everything is evolving
and there's no fixed human nature we can
evolve toward utopia
and that's what they they think they're
going to do and they're going to make
you evolve toward utopia dammit
they're going to make you evolve toward
utopia or you are going to die
trying because sometimes you got to
crack a few eggs to make an omelet
i think that's where a lot of this
rancor comes from
they're going after everybody they're
going after melania for goodness sakes
did you hear how they're going after
melania
they found a secret tape some some woman
betrays her
friend melania and releases tapes of
phone calls that they've had
in which melania is sort of venting
about the negative press that she gets
and how she's very unfairly criticized
she leaks it
plays it on cnn they say i'm completed
i'm the same like him i support him i
don't say enough i don't do enough no
where
about christmas stuff and decoration but
i need to do it right
yeah but imagine 100 you have no choice
and okay and then i do it and i say that
i'm working on christmas uh planning for
the christmas
and they said oh what about the children
that they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom
i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
i love her i love her i would
i would charge into battle for that
woman she is
so great she's so elegant she's funny
apparently too didn't realize that
i love that thing i'm doing the
criticizing with the christmas
decorations who gives
come on the christmas i'm doing my best
and it's true she's being completely
unfairly criticized they're accusing her
of
separating children or whatever they go
after trump for
for an obama era policy actually was a
policy was used under obama it actually
goes all the way back
to bill clinton's administration but you
never heard peep about it
until donald trump comes around and they
say all sorts of horrible things about
this woman
and now they're hoping that she and her
husband die at least
they're explicitly saying they want her
husband to die
these are these are big democrat
staffers saying that
isn't it so funny that the left which
talks about
how they just want to save humanity they
love humanity the virus they're going to
stop the virus
and save mankind while they're wishing
for the salvation of humanity they're
wishing for the death of individual
humans
that's so weird that's that's what they
always do
they want to save the world from global
warming they want to save the world from
this they want to save the world from
that
humanity but not individual humans
they hate individual humans very often
as you see from what they're tweeting at
the president
sort of things they're doing to
individual republicans
and they they hate those individual
humans because they hate human nature
humanity in the abstract they like very
much but that humanity has nothing to do
with
humans because it ignores human nature
and their politics ignores human nature
and they get more and more frustrated as
their utopian schemes don't work because
utopia means
no place at all you know topia place
no place it doesn't exist and they are
going to keep
banging their heads against the wall
trying to make their manifestos and
their ideologies work
and human nature is going to remain the
same stubborn
and they are going to get angrier and
angrier and angrier
if you enjoyed that video and i would
hope that you did
please be sure to hit the subscribe
button so that all of the
befuddled radicals wading through the
wasteland
of youtube knows where they can get the
truth
thanks